in one of the wettest places on earth in
northeast India the bridges aren't built
they're grown the chair punji region is
one of the wettest on the planet and
this makes life very difficult one
problem is that when you build something
especially if you build it out of wood
it just rots but the local kasi tribe
found an interesting answer to this
problem along the fast-flowing rivers of
the mountains as a type of tree called
the ficus elastica which grows a
secondary root system above ground the
kasi saw an interesting opportunity in
this secondary root system they took
some hollowed-out logs and they laid the
roots in it and they let the roots
slowly grow until they reached the other
side of the river and in this way they
built a living root bridge no one knows
exactly when they started doing this
they think it's at least 500 years ago
is a 10 to 15 years to grow but they can
become incredibly strong and hold up to
50 people
they can also be enormous the longest
root bridges are over a hundred feet
long and they're still living there part
of the tree among the other kinds of
things that the kasi tribe has done is
built root ladders down the sides of
mountains they built a double decker
root bridge and it is their dedication
to creating these root bridges that has
kept them around and alive and the
CAHSEE are still making new bridges they
have recently started growing yet
another double decker root bridge which
should be ready to cross in about 10
years
click here to subscribe or click here to
watch our other videos what do you think
the world's greatest hidden wonders are
let me know in the comments and I can't
wait to hear all about them